okay this is pea peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips
and this is a
quick tutorial about how
bubble levels work or
get the bear above the cane string
levels um this is uh the coolest new
um
well in my opinion this is the coolest
new level type in soda saga
it's completely different than any other
type of
level we've seen before in a game and um
it's pretty straightforward but
we'll just talk about how it works so
that you know and if you have any
questions you can leave a comment
so you can see by the little
introduction screen that we have to
get the bear that's in the bubble to
float above the stream um
even though you can't see him here
there's rows involved and
basically you have to get the bear to
the row that is above the string in
order to move on
so this is one of the simplest
levels of course it's the first one you
can see just by making matches
we can easily move the bear until he
gets above the string
another thing to notice about this is
that it is
their soda already on the board
and that won't always be the case when
you play these types of levels
sometimes you have to pop bottles in
order to get them
to
fill up the board as you go
so you can't really even see the rows on
this one it um
like i mentioned this is the easiest one
and
i think most of the bears level the
bubble levels that you play later
will require you to
fill up the board as well
so here you can see he's trapped right
below the string
there are several ways we could get him
out
we could make the blue match which would
just let him slide up
or we could match these two together
because it'll make the cross and now he
is free and we've collected our three
bears that we need to collect
so i'm just going to pause for a second
and then find a level that
where we have to fill it up
and uh we'll talk about that
all right so this is one of the more
difficult
early um
you get the bear above the string levels
or bubble level
and as you can see that we only have one
row of soda right now
so we're gonna have to uh
pop bottles in order to get the board to
fill up so that we can get him above the
line
and the strategy depends you know it
varies from
board to board
the um
the main thing is
you you always kind of want to keep the
keep the bear moving up
while popping bottles at the same time
fish can help out a lot because they'll
go right after the bottles for you
special candies will help out especially
if you can make combinations of specials
with fish
because they'll that'll take out
multiple
bottles at the same time usually
and just like in the other soda levels
to pop the bottles levels
it's a little bit tricky sometimes to um
to think about the matches are going to
play out because
where the soda line is they're basically
two separate boards
everything above the line is going to be
dropping down normally like in a regular
match 3 game
and then everything in that's submerged
in the soda will be floating up
so it's it doesn't work
as in such a straightforward way which
is one of the things that makes this
game really fun and interesting as far
as i'm concerned
all right so here we can you know we can
use the striped candy to pop the bottle
and um set off the other
special candy there and you can see that
brings up the board and it once that
happens it'll scroll to reveal more of
the level
this is another thing that i really like
about this game compared to the original
is um
it has scrolling boards almost like
diamond digger saga does
except here
they're all connected it's not real it's
all one single board you just can't see
the whole thing at the same time
so you don't get a you know added moves
when you move from one to the next like
you do in diamond digger
but i mean to me that that's something
we've never seen before in a match three
and it's something that makes it you
know really
a different type of game altogether um
you know there's a million
regular match three games out there that
basically just use the same mechanics um
some are easy some are hard
um most are boring in my opinion
um
and this is what makes this game really
cool is that
you
know we see brand new things that we've
never seen before
so you know we have trap bottles we have
to get them out of the um
out of the licorice
if we can't move it up
fast enough we will fail and um
we got 14 moves up there's pretty good
chance that we might fail this time
you can shoot bottles from anywhere with
the with a special candy and i recommend
you do that whenever you can
you can see that when the soda level
rises that the cascades have been going
down instead of up
which is pretty neat
you know sometimes you can feel like oh
man i'm not going to finish the level
because the bear is away at the bottom
or something but
a well-timed cascade can
help you out just like it does in a
regular game except for your cascade
it'll be going upwards instead of that
lens
and um
you can see how things are a little bit
a little bit strange compare
based on the um
on the gravity of the board but
if you just think things through you can
you can
make your way up
now here's a here's an example of
there's really nothing that we can do to
get the bear above this this line right
here unless we raise the soda level a
little bit more
so
when you get to a situation like this
especially in some of the more
challenging levels
one of the things that you want to keep
in mind is
even though you only have to get it one
row above the line
sometimes it can be a lot of help to get
the soda to fill up the entire board so
that you can arrange
your matches above the line a little bit
easier instead of having to deal with
you know pieces going up and pieces
falling down
once the entire board is filled with
soda it'll work just like
all the all the it'll work just like a
regular board just in reverse all the
pieces will be going up
so that's about all there is to that um
there's definitely some really
challenging ones
later and then we have guides and videos
that you can watch to see how to get
past those
if you have any questions about how
these levels work leave a comment below
please like the video if you found it
helpful and visit
candycrushsodusagatips.com for all
the information you need to learn how to
play this game and get get the most out
of it
thanks